i haven't had ice cream yet
i uh the trash carts in taiwan
sounds like ice cream trucks
yeah that was one of the favorite parts
of round two people love
that rick rick puff flavored ice cream
that know their perception nor
non-perception flavor
[Music]
the flavor of dependent origination
do all those dharma words are like great
for like
ice cream names or like sneaker names
yes
that's good we will leverage
consciousness yeah
air jordan 4 the two kananas
let's get to the questions boom
frank and i were crowd sourcing
epic questions from you guys for our
first
infinite bra ama and
let's jump right in to the questions
which we have
ranked approximately 20 of them based on
what we
felt were not only of high interest for
answers for you guys overall to
here but also ones that we felt like we
could actually engage with
so we'll have frank start us off
our first question is in your journey
did you at some point have to let go of
the attachment to your meat
suit or did it fall off on itself
um never i've never
had to consciously detach myself
from doing anything on the spiritual
path
the only thing that i did throughout
this whole path
was meditate and do self-inquiry
two to three hours every day
aside from that i just did whatever the
[ __ ] i wanted to do
and i think that could be a plus
in a sense that in a way
trying to stop yourself from doing
something is also ego
right on the spiritual path something
you go like should i stop working out
because that's ego well
the desire to try to stop working out is
also equal
and one of the best ways to dissolve the
ego
is to exhaust it bro
is to love yourself accept your shadows
accept your desires so completely that
you don't see them anymore you penetrate
through them
by loving it i love every
particle in your being desire or no
desire
so your entire character the separate
itself
can dissolve into love
and die and that's how you manifest all
of reality
dying into the extraordinary
so i did not detach myself from working
out but i would say that it does
drop off automatically like whatever it
isn't
beneficial to your journey
is going to drop away on its own
so while i still work out and i've been
working out through my whole entire
journey
the attachment to the outcome of
working out gets less and less and less
you only enjoy the process at the end in
a sense
i like working out even more now because
every rap is eternal
every rap is timeless i can feel the
sensation every micro sensation on every
contraction and every extension
and i don't have a goal before i was
working out for that image of arno as
this or the future frankie in the head
now i'm just working out for the pure
sensations no other reason than
because i like it it feels good
now funny thing is
i don't get tired anymore when i work
out i don't get out of breath
if i do the same amounts in a single gym
session right now versus before
i can actually squeezing more sets more
wraps right now than before
why because first of all your whole body
is now relaxed why is your whole body
relaxed
after awakening because you're no longer
inside the head and behind the eyes
we spend so much of our energy trying to
maintain the illusion of separate so
kind of imagine
the separate self into existence that
takes a tremendous amount of brain power
bro
after you unhook awareness from inside
the head
to everywhere nowhere which has always
been the case
if you do physical tasks like running
working out
your conditions gets increased when i
say condition i mean like your work
capacity you don't get tired you don't
get out of breath as easily
yeah because when you live it's almost
like you're lifting through
the universal will when you lift it's
just a universe lifting
when you eat just the universe eating i
don't have to think about what i have to
do an accent
i don't have to think about what i eat
it's on autopilot
and i have no attachment to my body
right now like i could be a fat lord
tomorrow wake up morning and be a fat
lord i will not give a [ __ ]
but while nothing matters anyway would
you rather be a
spiritual shredded [ __ ] or a spiritual
pet [ __ ]
yeah you don't really have to let go of
anything because what is detrimental to
your journey is
always going to dissolve by itself if
you do the practice
if you do the inquiries because whatever
is not necessary is gonna
automatically gets sucked back into the
void
you just have to make sure that you're
aligned
authentic to you it's all about
authenticity
and both both of those
both of those yeah because after a while
you kind of
you can sense the energy like
my entire um my entire life before
awakening i had to think about whether
i'm doing this for good or for bad like
is it good for my
character is it bad for my character but
after awakening you don't think about
that anymore
you just get a kind of like sense you
don't think about it you just kind of
get
like a sixth sense there's nothing
intellectual about just kind of get a
sense is this a line this is what i'm
gonna do align with the truth or not
and so far lifting weights has
absolutely no effect on my alignment
with truth in fact when i'm working now
when i'm really like
dying into every rap i'm more in line
than
you know not lifting maybe i don't know
but
i'm just saying that when i'm working
now i'm not i'm
not less aligned with the truth than
when i'm
not working out so i like the
answer of both because the flower
effortlessly blossoms towards the sun
so that's the falling off itself but
that happens simultaneously
as the egoic grasping
also dissolves right you detach
yourself and those happen simultaneously
let's move to the second question
can a bipolar person awaken slash
how does bipolar play a part in
awakening
actually wrote an answer to that already
somebody already asked
me so because i display a lot of bipolar
tendencies
pre-awakening um so i wrote it down
i had some bipolar tendencies and
i think i gave up
wait a second hold on a second okay
sorry i right or wrong
so i had some bipolar tendencies before
awakening
and i think that gave me an edge to
meditation i can dissolve
and sync up sensations much quicker and
more efficiently with more power
same with adhd which is all about
contracting your attention to a single
point of
laser beam by excluding everything else
and vice versa
the more you can contract the more you
can expand and relax
now all i have to do is totally let go
and relax the mind and the big mind
consciousness
is literally glued to the sky as the sky
with no distance and separation
and the whole world is not just inside
it but made
up of the same knowing same with
my years of struggling with sex
addiction pre-path
the energy used to pull girls is sucked
back into the kundalini
to [ __ ] the universe while the universe
[ __ ] me and after the big bang
i haven't suffered the slightest bit
same with many awakened individuals who
took a quantum leap
over the mind and reached nirvana many
had quote-unquote mental illnesses
they're already tapping into or dancing
at the edge of the mind
all you need to do is the right methods
and techniques and a little push
but on this path you transcend the mind
so insanity
insanity is no longer relevant the
duality between insanity and sanity is
transcendent
it's seen through as empty and
nonsensical neither inside or outside
i think this is why this path
uh makes certain artists and musicians
and writers
better
for certain writers the musicians found
more success on the path
because they're really the same thing
a lot of artists and musicians already
at the edge of the minds
and they're looking for truth they're
trying to use the medium of
writings and art and music
to try to dissolve the separation that's
why you get a glimpse of the
transcendence when you hear beautiful
pieces of music and such
yeah but you know spirituality is just a
more direct way
to embody that truth without the medium
of
the middle man of say uh art or sex or
music things like that
but this isn't a glorified mental
illness
if you're a naturally calm person
there's an advantage to that as well
the point is if you are sincere and
serious about the path and truth
there will be a divine gravitational
pull
towards universal totality
and whatever body my advantage or
disadvantage that you have
will be rewired and realigned to fit the
path
until perception we entangle itself and
stretches to infinity
yeah perfect
it's always nice when there's already
been a well
thought out detailed reply on it
that you can pull up to answer that's
great
so we'll also put all these questions
below and then maybe later time stamp
them to help you guys out so you guys
can sift
through the exact time that the
questions were
answered go ahead frank the uh the
mystical heist
uh that you kind of do in the past is
actually very
close to the bipolar manic episode
i mean if you don't look at if you don't
quantify things as being spiritual
or this is a kundalini awakening or this
is
uh mental illness like at the cellular
level maybe
it's not that much different because
what is schizophrenia
schizophrenia is the process of the
breaking down of the ego
so during the process of awakening a lot
of people actually go through
psychotic episodes that is very
uh closely aligned with the symptoms of
bipolar disorder and schizophrenia
because you realize you're not the self
you're not the ego what is that
that schizophrenic
so you wake up from the ego the process
can feel extremely schizophrenic
but then after you return to the natural
state you realize that
this is the first time i ever
experienced sanity again transcending
the duality between insanity and sanity
so even saying that insanity is already
making a distinction so we talked about
that in the
first podcast where the natural state is
the unaltered state of consciousness
where during the awakening process where
you experience the dark night of the
soul and the spiritual highs the kind of
linear awakenings where you consciously
explosive universe
which is two sentences in coin all that
is still ultra state of consciousness
so when people ask me man i'm afraid i'm
gonna go insane well
even before you got into spirituality
and experience all these mystical states
you were already critically insane so
you don't need to ground yourself
in clinical sanity during the spiritual
path because you'll be insane all your
life and during the process
there's just more insanity until you
just identify from all the states and go
to natural state and realize that before
awakening it's always identity
yeah i highly recommend tuning into
the absolute normie episode we just did
prior to this and
i would also highly recommend that given
your exact
blueprint to leverage
all of its nuances as gifts
on your path so see bipolar or whatever
it is
that is the deep conditionings or
traumas
leverage those on your path as your
gifts
as well as you can yes yes yes
and i would like to jump us into the
next
question and bring in the point that
frank mentioned
in the answer to the last question to
talk about this how do antidepressants
anti-anxiety medications etc effect
awakening
do these things prevent awakening frank
wet took us through the process of
when we undergo the contracted egoic
separate self-identity dissolving
especially when we've turned inward and
become
more abident in the formless
consciousness or awareness that
especially when we begin in a sense
declining
physicalism it can
very much trigger especially when you
start saying things like i am
god where you have in the east
you will have the applause
non-duality is being realized excellent
and in the west it will be get this
person to a medical
institute as soon as possible and so
you have what i've seen across my own
friends
and others where
the process
that we've described
can trigger family friends
society to medicate
the one that is awakening and that
we collectively will evolve and awaken
ourselves over time to synthesize
the east and west together better and to
become more aware of what awakening
truly is
and not prescribe the medications
at those times because if you look at
awakening it's you're waking up out of
society and out of the norms out of all
the conditions within society so in a
sense it's
completely flying against the face of
chronic normality right so a lot of uh
western psychologists or psychiatrists
they themselves don't have experiences
that people are undergoing when they
take on the spiritual path
and it's very tricky to navigate that
that's why people like daniel ingram
says that
we need more psychiatrists out there
therapist
that knows about the maps of insight and
about what people go through if not
directly experienced maybe they can read
about
some research on why some people when
they undertake the spiritual path
go through those different modes of
experiences got my mirror
psycho psychotic being psychotic
and i would just like to also add that
in the future
especially as we get even better at
neuropharmacology will get to a point
where we'll
leverage the entheogenic capacities
along with these neuropharmacologies
in the west to merge with the eastern
nondual spirituality and we'll be able
to really sort of awaken ourselves
faster
and faster so there is a positive
side as well that we have yet to really
unlock but frank's so on point that
it would be excellent for the
doctors training into the mcat for
example
to have a portion of it be around
the eastern medicines and spiritualities
holistic practice if you look at
spirituality the path of people
the stages that people go through stages
of insight it's almost universal
it's almost like that is what the mind
would go through when it's undergoing
the process
of this identification or
upgrading your consciousness even
soldiers when you look at soldiers
there's a lot of soldiers experience uh
god-like states during
battles because they're extremely
concentrated
when you're in an extremely concentrated
state when your life is at stake
you can access genres you can access
oneness
and what happens after the battle ptsd
what is that
darken out the soul after the spiritual
high you go to the spiritual laws unless
you truly
you know have a have an insight and lock
the spiritual highs and spiritual laws
when you have a permanent perception
shift with something like a fruition or
whatever
you're gonna cycle back and forth so
people don't understand the fact that
this is what the mind goes through
when it's put under those kind of
situations whether that's the spiritual
path or going in battles
or even if you take a lot of
psychedelics you're gonna go through the
same stages
the process of this identifying the
solution of the condition of the
separate self
or the process of getting into certain
very highly concentrated states
the experiences of that doesn't matter
what domain you're in it's almost
universal
and funny thing when you mention like
western psychiatrists because if you
look at what uh
ramana mahashi says if you just take the
exact same word that
romana says if you like a western
psychiatrist who has no idea about
eastern spirituality
read the wisdom of ramana
the western psychiatrist will think that
he's [ __ ] insane
if you just take the words at the
surface level
keep like this someone that needs to be
taken into the mental hospital
right so it's very
very interesting
whereas many people in the east would
look over at the
insanity of the west and say that they
need to go to the
spiritual monastery
okay cool next question is how to get
past
experiencing awareness as being
everywhere
okay so i think what he's asking is
how to go beyond even the initial stages
of non-duality
um in my videos i often talk about
illustrate with visual metaphors and
images about how awareness
creates a hook from the head actually
awareness doesn't get unhooked from the
heads it's already
not in the head from the middle direct
experience awareness is already
everywhere it's already panoramic at
360.
um but even before
you completely dissolve the center point
of the separate self you can experience
the 360 awareness
while still being locked inside the head
and behind the eyes
that's the same thing we talked about in
the earlier podcast where there's
a separate entity experiencing divine
versus the complete drop in a way of the
center or the self where it's just
divinity recognized in itself there's
only awareness being aware of itself
without the center point the perceiver
the hearer the thinker
so to get past that all you have to do
is continue the dissolution
now you got to the stage from dissolving
most of your egos
and now your identity is an awareness so
you abide in awareness to continue the
process of dissolution
and if you're still in the center and
you still perceive an awareness
as being this field of panoramic uh
consciousness while still feel like
you're in the head perceiving that
all you have to do is just pay attention
to dissolving the aggregates
you dissolve the seer dissolve the hear
dissolve the feeler the doer the thinker
and you realize all those different
aggregates are just more solidified
sensations
cluster around your body or in the head
that's trying to take credit trying to
hijack other sensations
as being self
another way to do this that's the moral
of the passionate kind of pathways
dissolve conditions by uh penetrating
through sensations but
you could also do self-inquiry if you
can be aware of awareness
that you can still objectify it so
you're in here in the center perceiving
awareness do you see awareness
are you conscious of this infinite
consciousness if yes
then that could still be disidentified
from
first you say i'm not the ego then you
say i'm not awareness and i'm not
consciousness
and eventually you're gonna run into a
wall where the observer is observing
the observed where you're observing the
observer there's like a screen here
and then the screen is looking at itself
and then the next step
is to surrender and disappear
into the what is
perfect next excellent
we touched a little bit on this a little
bit ago
what is an ego death is it possible that
the ego has many lives
um yes so first of all on the ultimate
picture there is no such thing as the
ego because we talked about how the ego
is just contracted sensation contracted
energy
where god consciousness is just more
expensive energy but it's the same
clinical particle of subjective
experience
which can be broken down to sensations
so
there really is no ego except for
contracted sensations
so the ego was never alive gonna go to
life
so there is no such thing as ego death
so it would be fair to say that ego
equals contracted sensations yes
or identify sensations contracted
identified sensations
yes so the ego was nervous because what
is the ego the ego is just a thought
it's just a thought fundamentally no
different from any other thoughts that's
arising and passing out of nowhere any
direct experience
this the thought of the self is no
different from the thought of a bird or
sky or tree right
but then due to conditioning we tend to
contract the energy around this thought
of the ego
right so if the thought of the ego is
just more sensations
and if sensations in them themselves are
not aware the ego
was never alive what is aware awareness
is aware
awareness is aware of the ego awareness
is aware of the sound of birds
awareness is aware of your body
but in and of themselves body
ego birth in your favorite experience
is not you know where it's not aware
you see the point there sensations in
themselves are like objects
it's awareness that's aware of itself
right
this is really hard to explain but look
you're doing a good job
they look at the ego like a cop when i
perceive my ego it's the same thing as
perceiving the problem
right we mistaken the ego to be
something that's alive that's doing the
proceeding
but there was no such an entity
saying that the ego is alive it's like
saying the cop is alive
well you could say that yeah everything
is alive because everything is god you
could say that too
but if you want to do this kind of self
finger practice um
it's efficient to remind yourself that
the ego was never alive
because sensations are not alive and
conscious only consciousness is
conscious
so the only way to transcend the ego is
not to kill the ego because you can't
kill
something that's not alive you try to
come up with something else like killer
of the ego just more ego
it's just more contractions there's more
identities
the only thing you can do is abiding
about this new identity this new ground
and then
continue to dissolve solidities
observations
i like all the whole idea of the ego
that's the first thing just let go of
the idea that there isn't an ego in the
first place
ego is not an entity some of you made up
if you can if you make something up you
can stop making it up right now
you're imagining the ego into existence
moment to moment
in general the seeking impulse
arises in the contracted conditioned
separate self and the turn is
after exhausting everything outward for
peace and happiness the turn is
inward and then the process as frank
described in the last episode absolute
normie
is step by step rather than creating
these names of ego dissolution
and step it's just overall more and more
relaxation into the dissolving of
all of those conditions separate self
yes
and then that's the what can be said as
these
potential possible ego many lives
because i described it in the last
episode as well
and every single one of these points
there has been
this cheeky [ __ ] re-emergence
latching on spiritual [ __ ] identity now
this guy knows he must post and share
with other people
yeah so the only thing you can do is
just just express just express
just express the ego to its fullest
extent until you exhaust itself
that's why spirituality is always cut
away at the end of people's journey
after they exhausted all the other ego
tendencies
so the only thing you can do to dissolve
the ego is witness
it accept it and love it
love the ego to death love didn't get to
death
when you love the ego to death it
dissolves into love with a capital l
and yes the ego can have many lives just
like what we talked about in the
absolute video
transcendence of the self you can have a
temporary transcendence of the ego
an experience but the ego always comes
back
because it's an experience not a
full-blown permanent realization
so let's go through the three stages
again first you have intellectual
understanding
with the mind second you have an
experience of that understanding a
temporary glimpse
into truth and experience but ego always
comes back because the experiences are
not permanent
they come and go third you lock that
experience
into a realization a permanent
perceptual shift to what is
you realize that whoa there was never a
self to begin with
and this is true for everyone there was
never an ego to be the ego was never
alive
you see through the true nature of what
makes up an ego
you can never believe it again
yet it's our greatest tool the
contracted
separate self with all of its
conditionings and attachments and
cravings and aversions is the greatest
tool to spirituality it's the big
sledgehammer of
suffering yeah it's like this bro um
well the ego has to be so big and you
suffer so much there's no way out that's
why i lost so many seekers
they start sneaking because they're
suffering so much or they have huge
eagles a lot of like celebrities
and uh whatever they go through this
entire life just being the ego and they
just
the ego just started to exhaust itself
like okay now
mike tyson now i'm gonna smoke some
five-minute meal dmt
right um and it's funny because it's the
the seeker has to exhaust itself
so before the secret is completely
exhausted the secret
the egoic state of the secret it's okay
to be super strong it's all gonna be
like i'm gonna gain light
i'm gonna get spiritual especially
awaken i'm gonna be a spiritual [ __ ]
sure why not just accept that
and then you realize at the end of the
path there is no such thing as the ego
self no self but just different
contraction expansion of sensations
that's it
and the whole path becomes void you know
what somebody uh said to me today
frank isn't it just a trap that you
think you're done well let me tell you
there's two biggest trap in spirituality
first
thinking that you're not done second
thinking you're done
this is so good because you're telling
the non-duality
everything that non-dual teachers say is
true there's nothing to do you're full
in line right now
but you might not recognize this but it
you might not fully recognize this truth
right away
but it's just as much of a trap as
thinking that there's more to go there's
always more to go there's
always more outstanding consciousness
sure there is
we can continue to explore how to set up
consciousness
and after you realize emptiness and
close the circuit of infinity
you can continue to be a more
compassionate person
or make better ice creams
but the thing i always emphasize is that
at least the inside axis the wisdom axis
realizing what has always been the case
has an end point
when infinity closes it on itself where
can you go except for looping back in
itself
infinitely can i go anywhere else right
here right now
you cannot get any more infinitely
infinite you can't get any more empty
than empty
but how you fill this emptiness with
form
how you express this emptiness through a
podcast or
through making ice creams making art
through teaching maybe
or through being a prostitute that's
infinitely full and complex
you can always read more comic books and
be a better boyfriend
and don't make a stay on your toilet
brah don't be an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
literally pure potential
yes pure potential it's like the state
is almost like that before
there was a form the the potentiality
before
there was manifestation
and even now the pure potential
now also yes yes also it's all it's it's
both
manifested and they are manifested yeah
infinite possibilities baby pure
potential
how do you keep going if it gets
scary well there was this quote that i
heard from
zayn master he said what is a zen master
he is nothing but
a tour guide to take you from heaven to
hell
simultaneously and very quickly you
think you can go to heaven without going
to hell
think again the two sides of the same
coin
so i'll say spiritual awakening is about
transcending the duality between heaven
and hell
but the only way to transcend this
duality to get into that space
that gives rise and is outside of the
union circle of both heaven and hell
is to go through them all cycle back and
forth but they haven't held heaven hell
continuously until you
abide in that source that gives rise to
both
so how do you keep going if it gets
crazy the one thing i like to remind
people when they're going through like
you know really rough times on the path
is
your consciousness is getting upgraded
you cannot experience upgrade without
some intentions
without resistance think of fitness you
think your muscles can grow
if you don't experience some sort of
pain and tension while lifting
no every growth happens because of
stress and tension but if it gets too
crazy
maybe you should see a psychiatrist i
don't know
there's a fine line here like i don't
want to just tell people that i mean
some people really have a tough time
with this some people go through like
true mental breakdowns that they can't
even function and for that kind of
people
it's not the wisest to advise them to me
hey man this is all part of the
spirituality meditating
that might not be good advice so one of
the
one of the cores for what you just were
sharing
is that upon this
turning inward and deepening of
spiritual awakening and
dissolving of the conditioned separate
self
that it's actually
really important to take this piece of
wisdom
which is if you can because you might
not be able to hear it right now
but do not take the
minor awakenings that you're having and
go
and begin zealously sharing them with
your family
and friends and community and society
because you don't know
who is going to slap
the gold right out of your hands
and it's better for you to
specifically identify people
that would be good
for this exact topic for example
all the people that reach out to frank
right now
and the people that are reaching out to
me
are people that have had
parts of this spiritual awakening and
now
what is happening is
leveraging somebody else that
has been there done that and
also that understands and can be
a valuable resource and that
is loving and compassionate and wise in
their
sharing and like we mentioned on the
absolute normie episode
the more emptied out the more it enables
one who is approaching to get their own
chakras unblocked as well
so really keep
vigilance with upon these awakenings
to okay who is a truly trusted person
to talk to about this the amount of
people that message me
and say that
you're the person that i know that i'm
gonna go to about
spiritual awakening stuff because they
know that
it's somebody that they know that they
can trust because if they turn to their
family the family will slap it out of
their hands
and that can promulgate some of the
scariness stuff
is oh my gosh they're telling me they're
going to take me to a hospital now
we touched on that a little bit earlier
as well so
really find that satsang that truth
community
really find that as along your path
cool all right
please touch on the concept of going
meta
uh going meta is basically just
going to the next level and then observe
the level you were in before from the
more transcendental perspective
and i think the whole process of
spirituality is about going meta
first you're an ego and then you witness
the ego from awareness
and then you become aware of awareness
that's also great meta
that's why in a lot of my videos i like
to use like uh visual metaphors of a
screen
and then you have zoom out from between
there's another screen on the screen on
the screen we've all seen that right um
that's going meta the infinite fractals
that's the ultimate
metaphor because it's only from
a higher perspective can you dissolve
and let go of the previous one because
the mind cannot understand itself
an ego can never kill itself it's only
by going meta
can you absorb
and disidentify from and comprehend the
previous
level so whatever level that you're on
right now go meta
keep going meta until the
circle closes in on itself when this
madness
the meta understand i'm experiencing
right now is very different from before
before i'll be like witnessed something
from below but now the metalness is it's
almost like
it's just that it's that that's the
ultimate meta it's when
if the loop closes on itself that's the
ultimate matter
the state validates some tail universe
[ __ ] itself that's the ultimate meta
when every moment is just that's the
ultimate matter but before you get to
this point you're gonna have to be meta
from
one perspective and then witness another
perspective and the two can be different
but ultimately when you close the loop
it's just the same
methodness just god fab into itself
everything is already meta so it's by
natural that the spiritual path is about
going meta
if you look at all the arts a lot of
like post-modern literature
it's all about going meta why are they
going meta they're like thinking about
this thing
they think about the situation they're
trying to create something creative out
of this current situation
and then boom they go to another level
that's why a lot of like post-modern
like literature and
films you see a lot of stuff that is
going meta
like being john malkovich even like
matrix is kind of like going better
there's a lot of examples of scenes
where you know you think this is the
reality
then boom like o-o-a have you seen o-a
where like you think this is reality but
boom it's a movie set that's going meta
and then you're like holy [ __ ] that's a
movie set then you're going better from
going better
you're like oh [ __ ] i'm watching the
movie set up a movie set but movie set
that's gonna matter
but i don't think that you learn
anything to understand anything you have
to go meta it's the most important super
weapon of the mind
the mind has the ability to disidentify
from itself and witness itself
from a higher perspective the whole
process of being a human is going meta
yep that beautiful
perfect
would you recommend 5meodmt during or
instead of meditation for someone who
does
not have significant chemical experience
um it all depends on the individual um
it all depends on the individual i used
to recommend
uh 5mu dmt only to people that have
meditated for like at least like 5 000
hours
but i don't know if i mean i can't say
that because
i have a biased tendency towards uh
just acquiring those states that i'm
talking about naturally because
even though i've done uh stuff like 5m
or dmt
all my shifts all my big bangs and you
know
all my big crunches all my awakenings
were the result
like true general awakenings i had a
permanent shift
perception shift all my genuine
awakenings
were the result of applying the
technique naturally
self inquiry departure uh zonchen do
nothing meditation stuff like that
so i i don't know i don't know i think
if you have a good base
i think if you have a good base of
either one you could
because like meditation could be just as
critical dangerous these people can go
to a vipassana retreat
and they could go crazy just like people
can take a lsd trip
for 12 hours and they can feel like
they're going insane so
ultimately there really is no different
right
so but i would say the two feet on each
other if you have a good base doing
meditation then
um dmt might be a little bit quicker
safer
you might feel a little bit more
grounded when doing gmt
uh or if you someone likes uh
like little girl who's done like so much
dmt and he's like super grounded in his
like five-minute world trip
if he goes to like a 30-day retreat
maybe like it'd be easy for him because
he's already kind of like wired his
brain to experience all those different
crazy alter states on
500 dmt
if we take what
five amio dmt is we classify it as an
entheogen so unleashing god within
and we
we add that to the list of
like we were describing the do nothing
meditation
vipassana self-inquiry
etc
we want these two to complement each
other
so just remember that antiogens are not
necessarily a substitute
but they're a complement
so especially if you don't have
significant
and theogenic experience i would highly
recommend
especially five meow
dmt is known specifically as
this god molecule rocketing you
into the nature and
undergoing about a half dozen or so
experiences with five amino dmt myself
i've done them specifically with people
that are
extremely well trained and shamanic in
the practice
and i would also recommend that as well
and at a much lower dose
so maybe a fourth or something of the
recommended
dose to start especially without
significant chemical experience
similar to when people inquire into my
entheogenic experience with magic
mushrooms
i will definitely as frank mentioned
individual
personalize the recommendation
so typically starting off with something
like a fourth
of a gram can be a great little micro
dosing experience for magic mushrooms
so now specifically
during has been really interesting i
also underwent a process of intaking
some lsd towards the end
of my vipassana meditation retreat
one of one of them one of the later ones
that i attended
and that was very interesting i would i
would definitely encourage
playing with the
self-inquiry or meditation
practice simultaneously with entheogens
actually it's probably been the most
profound thing
that i could recommend is getting a
really solid foundation
in these stages that frank and i
unpacked in the absolute normie episode
and then to partake in using anthogens
in larger doses once you have
sort of built up your ability to handle
that
about twice a year so about once every
six months
and you'll experience
typically a deepening and confirming
of what you've been experiencing on the
meditation side of things yeah
to me uh psychedelic trips are just
they're glimpses to what's possible
in the natural in the uh in the natural
state sorry not the natural state but
during the process because natural state
is beyond both psychedelics and
meditation it's funny because when you
reach natural state you realize the
first thought i had
after my realization is like this thing
has nothing to do with psychedelics
it has nothing to do with meditation
about spirituality
all traditions all methods are void
they're just tools to ejaculate yourself
out of the dreamscape but once you're
out you realize that all those methods
still belong to the dreamscape so in
that sense both meditation
and psychedelics are just tools and it's
not like one is better than the other
they're just tools for you to dissolve
conditionings and the effects of it
in some sense is the byproduct of that
dissolution
and in my own experience whatever you
can glimpse
on psychedelics is a preview a window
into what you can experience naturally
and you prime yourself to access those
states doing genres or
smarties things like that but at the end
you could have no experience at all is
still return to a natural day because
some people
barely had any experiences through other
paths so i don't because i talk about
experience a lot because my own path is
crazy experiences
because i'm a crazy [ __ ] this is
my personality
right i'm always very extreme so my
passion is going to be
green but a lot of people they try to
master experiences onto mine
which i think is a mistake
because some people barely had any
experience because again realization is
not an experience
you can have a lot of realizations and
if you're a character your body mind is
already pretty pure
and there's not a lot of conditions to
dissolve
you might not feel a lot of crazy
experiences and that's probably good
because then you have less things to let
go of
i mean experiences are beautiful you
know i look back on the path i'm like
holy [ __ ] those experiences man
wow cosmic sex blah blah blah
but at the end you have to let go of
each one of them you have to let go of
each one of your spiritualizations
each one of your spiritual experiences
you chase them they don't they don't go
away you can still access them but
you transcend them because holding on to
any particular state
they do clingy and suffering
what is the difference between cessation
in meditation
stream entry and going unconscious
forgetting where your mind went
the difference is when you enter
succession through meditation you're
actually
you either go through all the genres you
go through all age on us and you slip
into succession
which means that by this point your
mind's already being primed you're
training your mind
to kind of play fitness to get into that
state which means that you're
making changes to the neuroplasticity of
your brain at the cellular level
whereas falling asleep is falling asleep
but the state itself the dreamless state
versus the death state of secession is
the same
but the point of a succession is not the
state stateless state itself because
non-existence nothing to talk about
right it's the it's the inside
the entrance into it and the returning
from it that is the most important
so you can enter succession through a
very high concentrated state
and that change your mind to operate at
a different level
and when you see particle by particle
how each
your entire field of experience is
constructed it's fabricated part of that
particle
they disappear into nothing into depth
and you come back and you see how
your entire universe is then
reconstructed again
you understand the deep experiential
level that oh it's all just a
fabrication but during sleep you're not
going to get that you're not going to
get that from just falling asleep
you're not going to get the inside unit
how do you know when you've hit stream
entry ah
there we go man i
i gotta trash this oh okay
is he charging take your time
really you guys okay with this we're
empty full
he you know the the
this podcast is so long my camera i
can't take it
the absolute normie episode was two
whole hours
we've gotten through half of our
questions which is pretty good
in about an hour yeah you're not going
to edit this right because uh what about
the pauses and stuff
yeah we're streaming now and we will
keep the asset up yeah we'll just keep
the asset up
and then
what we will do is we will time stamp
the specific
questions to help everyone out
when they stay
okay it's charging now okay but then the
computer is at seven percent i think we
should uh try to hurry up
why don't you charge the computer
instead and then
we'll um don't worry about the gopro for
now
or or find a second charger i have a
second charger
there you go that's even better solution
okay so we got a
second charger
not done
[Music]
we
thanks for tuning in everyone
life talking to life
for one intelligence talking to itself
papa
uh
okay
i got a charger
i got a charger yay
i got a charger
oh okay okay okay
good bro oh all right
yes
i just put a battery in here that's
right
all right there we go
all right all right
okay so do you have your
laptop connected to power
yes no i don't i gotta do that right now
good there we go okay all right
so what what's next um stream entry
okay um
the surest way that you know your
instrumentary is if you had a fruition
or a succession
which is what we talked about earlier um
see
when you reach a succession it's most
likely that you've gone through all the
genres and each drama is just a
level to identify a level of the mind
that gets
is embedded that's how you move from
jhana to china
right um so once you hit a succession
that means
a good amount of your conditioning in
your mind of the dream state has been
disidentified from
that's why a secession is one of the key
factors or indicators of stream entry
but um not everybody
reports from entries sorry not everybody
reports the sessions
there are people who don't follow the
passionate path have definitely hits
your mentoring
just by seeing through the dissolution
of the self uh but don't they don't
report
um successions and some teachers like
daniel ingram think that you have to
have a decision or there's no awakening
other people don't other people are like
you know you don't decisions aren't even
interesting
and some other teachers think that you
might have a cessation you just don't
know because especially
very quick you just kind of blink out
existence and come back
so you might have a cessation you don't
even know it
so how do you know if history mainstream
aside from
a succession is
art instrumentary at least from my
personal experience the first thing i
noticed
from moment to moment experience is the
perspective shift where
consciousness or awareness is not
unhooked from the head and there's this
bubble of
panoramic field that's surrounding
the character but after she mentioned
this bubble is still very limited it's
very small
it's not like infinite it's there you
can still sense the distortion in the
field there's still like a bubble here
so i was walking around like
like perceive the world through this
bubble right and then as you go
down to the path the bubble gets bigger
and bigger eventually when the self
completely dissolves the bubble also pop
so another way to know that your history
is that you feel like awareness is
somehow unhooked
from the head that's why people ask me
if i have instrumentary one of the first
questions that i ask
is where is your awareness now uh your
relationship to
the self and if you can clearly see
without a doubt
that the ego of the self is constructed
that's a fabrication that's imaginary
then there's a pretty good chance that
instrumentary
another one is reduction of suffering
even after extreme entry for me it was
like one percent of wow
that's a really profound one so
we could even potentially say that
stream entry
could be just realizing
how much of a falsity
ego and separate self is
you can say that so after stream entry
there's always going to be a reduction
of suffering battery that reduction
could be five percent
hmm that's great yeah
yeah because you have this a new space
for the ego to operate after you make
sure there's still a cell there's still
separation there's certainly equal but
you have this much more spacious field
to operate
and this relates to you go one level
meta which so almost like each level you
go meta
there's a decrease in suffering yeah
there's a decrease in suffering because
the the character gets smaller and
smaller
from inside the head to you know then
you witness the character from
the awareness and then you dissolve even
the witness and then now you're
abiding in the godhead and the suffering
gets reduced more and more and more as
the character
gets smaller and smaller and smaller
upon the solution
excellent okay now let's do please
explain the three doors to cessation
the three doors to succession uh the
first door
the first door you have uh the suffering
door
the suffering door is when
you've peeled away all your
identifications what and who you thought
you were
and there's always going to be suffering
there
because you're it's like skinning
yourself alive
until you hit a succession
well of course one section is not gonna
you're not gonna peel everything off
there's just one go right so
you go through sessions uh many many
times and you could go through the
suffering door many many times
or you can go through the other two
doors each one of those doors would
uh succession operation will occur uh
the second door
uh it's not an order this is you know
i'm just saying
the different doors the second door is
at the door of no self
the door of itself is when you start to
witness
the ego from the clinical screen of god
so before you and the screen of the ego
and then you witness the screen of the
ego from the screen of god and then
as they get closer and closer boom
lights out this is succession
the screen of god swallows the screen of
the ego
that's going to matter that's the best
example for a meta
if you want to hit a succession just
keep going meta until
and you realize they're actually the
same thing that the person looking out
through the
eyes behind the head is the same as
the observer it's the same as the
godhead but then before you realize that
the same before you completely dissolve
the duality between the observer and
observe do you think they're separate
so you create two screens on the screen
of the frank
the screen of god and then
they merge as one that's how you go
through the
succession door of no self the third one
is
impermanence that's when you start to
dissolve uh
that's when you observe sensations at
the microscopic level
you go you know really fast really fast
really fast and
and then once you get down to the bottom
of everything you realize that hey
everything just
you know everything is actually uh
freeze frames
because what is a movie made out of a
movie is made up of different frames
right
and that's what gives rise to
impermanence it's just one framework
another dream of another framework
so when you go really deep into
impermanence they actually come to a
standstill where nothing is rising
nothing is passing
so actually you go through freeze frame
and then boom lights out because you
sort of like
you're entering that space between two
frames almost
so that's the impermanence store when
you observe impermanence there's such a
microscopic
fine-grained detail that you come to the
source
of movement that's in permanent store
so to observe that you just observe
sensations arising in passing right
and you go closer and closer to the
source of it see xi jinyoung said a lot
of people
can observe cessation rising but they
can't observe sensations passing
you need to observe both it's easier to
observe a sensation
sigh thought body sensations emotions
uh sound whatever that's popping
out from nowhere but then it's when you
follow it you follow it you follow it
you follow it and then it goes back
to that nowhere that's observing a very
micro sensation
through impermanence and a succession
happens
through the door of impermanence when
you're not just observing
one sensation arising in validation
you're actually observing the entire
field of your experience arising and
vanishing
so your entire field of experience
becomes this huge
sensation the whole universe become one
single sensation that
arise and pass that's impermanent to the
deepest level and that will lead to
session where the entire universe
vanishes and appears again
boom how is cessation like shadow work
on steroids
um see in my own experience
secession indicates a completion of a
cycle of insight
so you go through the whole cycle of
insight and then you get a question
so what constitutes a cycle of insight
you have several different stages
i'm not going to mention them all but
the
three most prominent stages are the
rising and passing away which is your
spiritual highs
and the darkness of the salt which is
spiritual laws now those are again just
a byproduct of this identifying from
your mind
and then you have equanimity after you
realize that wait a second
spiritual high and spiritual laws are
just two sides of the same coin you go
into a state of equality
you accept the situation
you just surrender and then after you
surrender you
disappear and die that's completely open
so all your stuff come out so you shall
work you're observing what's going on
you're like letting all the
all your shadows come out and again
shadow horse
you know what is the shadow but the
other side of the extreme of you know
the lights in the bliss right
so when a succession occurs it's
actually when
you have all the stuff all this
condition or separation masquerading as
either spiritual has a spiritual load
that just surface surface surface
and then you experience both of the
highs and lows and then you accept both
as being the same
you go through a state of equilibrium
and then boom when a succession happens
it's almost like boom you jump on to the
next level next dimension
you reset the brain you reset your uh
your reality
until you know you go to the next stage
and you go through the cycles again
again and again again
so a session when a decision happens
it's almost like you went through a
whole
cycle of cleanup and then
you go to the next cycle and then again
and again so each time a decision
happens
uh it's the end of a cycle of
dissolution
so it's almost like this black hole that
just sucked all your conditionings out
at once
after you you know let them out and then
you suck into the void and then you come
back alive and then you go through it
again that's why every time after a
succession you feel like
oh you feel like you're really it's
almost like you took a huge nap
why because you went through a cycle you
whatever shadows that you're working
with
at that moment was just left behind to
the previous dimension
as emptiness dissipates
the heart and mind into oneness
what does one extrapolate back into
reality
uh everything so i guess that is that
that's sort of that
i'm not sure what the end that question
really means but i think what he's
asking is
um after i i guess what he's asking is
after you realize
implement uh what's next i guess
partly but also i do feel like the
question is
asking about utility okay what is the
point of
being oneness after you realize the
emptiness or
as emptiness dissipates the heart and
mind
into oneness what does one extrapolate
back into reality
that is a state that is not
conditioned by separate self
so a state that is
perpetually spontaneously in rhythm with
life itself and
any time that the
it arises that there's something
an untruth around conditioning
you're gonna feel so much pain
that you will correct it
there's the utility of just
being an incredible
shepherd steward
of life
i think what he's asking is what do you
do after awakening
what do you do after you're biting down
to other oneness uh
you just live life well enjoy life
because after you realize emptiness
after you realize you're nothing you
become everything and everything you do
is awesome
every moment is complete in itself
everything everyone was timeless
eternal it just it just it's just
you just live life bro you live life to
the fullest
because once you become empty once you
disappear into reality every moment is
manifested
as the entire reality every single
moment what do you do then
you do eat ice cream you [ __ ]
you lift weights you sit in silence
you do nothing as it is
as it is yeah listen to music
you love you you love you want to learn
you
yeah and laugh both love and love
yeah exactly you want to fill the
emptiness
with the fullness of love like while uh
nisagara said
after realizing the wisdom of nothing
the only thing left to do is fill up
with love
and life which is the same thing
beautiful okay and this is a follow-up
to that is how is art
different after full awakening and how
do we cultivate ourselves to elevate our
pre-awakening
um like we said earlier a lot of artists
create just so they can get into the
transcendental state of oneness
that's why it's not just creativity it's
why we do drugs
it's why we have sex or in love go to
church
make money it's all about just merging
with the source
everything that we do
so art is no different art is just a
little bit more direct than to say maybe
making money but from the ultimate
perspective they're the same because
most of art comes from ego
you notice that from the perspective of
the natty state both art and making
money are the exact same thing people
are like oh my god i don't want to
i don't want to make money i hate
business man they're so shallow and
superficial i hate capitalism i'm gonna
be an artist
i'm gonna make really fine beautiful
looking art but that's also a
gratification of the ego it's just that
the effect of art could feel a little
bit more transcendental
if you couldn't go closer to um i don't
know buying a car
maybe no depends on who you are maybe
some people when they sit in the
mercedes-benz they go into
consciousness who knows right it's all
arbitrary
but yeah so you create you
cultivate yourselves to create art so
you can get a gist of the taste of
oneness
now after awakening um
at least for me personally i stop i
don't have desire to create art anymore
i like i make
i make youtube videos and i talk about
the stuff because
i don't know i don't know why i just do
it let's do it but if you look at my
videos now versus before before i was
when i was
identify as being an artist my work
actually looks very different um
so after awakening you make art not as
ants but as means to an answer or you
can communicate with the state
at least for me i can't speak other
people and you sort of you lost the
interest to even be
creative because every single moment is
creativity
in my direct experience every single
moment is
the entire universe manifesting and
creating itself because after you
dissolve the center what's left
the only thing that's left is the entire
universe creating itself from moment to
moment
and everything that you wanted out of
art and creativity and music
is right here right now every single
moment so you kind of lost that middle
middle man
before you use art as a middleman to get
to the state after you get to the state
kind of stopped caring about playing the
ballet making art enjoying all that
stuff i just don't do that much anymore
um
yeah but then it's still getting
manifested
because my previous life was an artist
so this this artistic program
uh is still somehow in the body so i use
art as a tool
to communicate awakening because that's
what my character did as a program
previously just like lifting
and i can continue to use that program
without any attachment as means to an
end without attaching myself to the
outcome
or doing it out of the identification of
being an artist
so in that sense you are going to make
after awakening if you were an artist
before and you still decide to be an
artist
out of just the natural inclination of
the universal wall
the art is probably going to look
different the content will be
different the way you create will be
different
you could just stop making art all
altogether but at that time you don't
care anymore
a lot of people ask me this question is
like oh i'm an artist i'm a dj i'm
afraid that after awakening
i might lose all creativity i don't want
to create anymore maybe dude but you get
something much better that by that time
you wouldn't care about losing
creativity or not wanting to be a dj
anymore you just wouldn't give a [ __ ] at
all
yeah seriously if you do it
awesome if you don't care
yeah the second part of the question how
do we cultivate ourselves to elevate our
pre-awakening
just ask the big question which is am i
a separate
self or am i part
of the entire
universe life
and what have i identified myself with
am i identified with this conditioning
or can i be identified as the entirety
of life
the universe itself and infinite
possibility
being my true nature and if you
just do that process of inquiry that
itself will not only
increase the awakening but it'll
increase the quality of your art
to be more and more about elevating the
planetary condition
and then
it seems like a lot of
what spontaneously arises
after full awakening seems to be
less of doing
for the sake of achievement
and more so
a very non-attached surrendered
unfolding to life
itself being art yeah that's why
vipassana is called art of living
i will say that like all the techniques
that i use uh to wake up like meditation
something
you're it's gonna carry over to uh
how you create art i mean pre-awakening
and also the creativity that you're
engaging in playing the violin for me
for example or a drawing painting
that's also going to carry over to your
contemplative fitness practice
because you're training your mind to
think differently to be creative to get
into certain states
right so practicing violin and
meditation at the end it's not that much
different you're applying concentration
you're implying emotions you're
um training your brain so to speak
right so any kind of art and creativity
stuff that you're doing
period awakening it's going to help you
with your practices and methods
for sure
all right could you have chosen whether
to
awaken or not um i don't know
i i'm not i'm not sure what this
question is asking really
um isn't it quite isn't it quite
straightforward
could i have chosen like let's like
let's say the same question is could i
have
chosen to be frank yang or could i have
chosen to be boom
i have chosen to be here right
well maybe also part of it has to do
with the
that infinite possibility which is
really interesting
because when you really tap into
like we were talking about in absolute
normally when you tap into
infinity you can see all of the little
atlases
and there's a lot of atlases that chased
after maya
that's a very interesting point wait
hold on let me get my
i like that one that's a good
visualization um
so it's almost like it's almost like
they're there there's an alice that's
already at the end of the path and
there's like so many different uh atlas
and then the one at the end is pulling
all the different atlas to
towards itself you know and then like
and then like so they're like waiting in
line one pulls the other the other
the one the front is putting one in the
back and then the ultimate the ultimate
absolute absolute atlas is like just
abide in the source as itself
and business this is exactly and this is
exactly what
the law of one teaches as that
sixth density higher self
which is this absolute atlas that we're
talking about
the bin there done that end of the path
acting as the mechanism that
assists all of the other atlases in the
infinite possibility
with guidance and then everyone you
imagine your path is doing that too
yep and this is life life is literally
the
optimal mechanism
for awakening so i think that
that the trajectory of consciousness is
to pull itself towards
london yes absolutely what is it
enlightenment is nothing more than you
know reality being itself right
so so consciousness is a natural
trajectory to return to its most natural
state because it's already in that state
you know to dissolve all of the separate
conditioning yeah yeah that's the
cosmological
mechanism that's what the painting
is is that it's the
the melting away of the illusory cage
and each of us has our own unique
illusory cage
and then we each
have a unique process of union yoga
with the nature where we
turn inward and we dissolve the separate
self-conditioned
cage you could call it a cageless cage
like you can call it a veilless veil or
a gateless gate
so definitely just play on the infinite
possibility space
and then pick what is in your highest
excitement
what is in that north star position and
if it is to
truly go through this very destructive
process of spiritual awakening
then do that if it's to get a
house and a wife and some kids do that
cool all right
do you think everyone should reach
enlightenment within the span of their
lifetime well we kind of just
talked about this a little bit as well
that this the whole cosmological
mechanism
is that itself yeah
perspective i don't think you should you
need to do anything
whatever is put in that north star
position so whether
yeah we're all gonna die anyway right so
the death
the death is nirvana we're all reaching
that we all
we're all moving towards romano
regardless of what we do some people
just like to get there faster
because they're uh
[Laughter]
uh some people have no choice um
but do i think anyone should do anything
or everyone should do anything no
no yeah in terms of
like an ordered civilizational
doctrine no but in terms of a
cosmological phenomena that's already
unfolding
yeah it's already happened all right
let's do
what are your thoughts on neo advice
teachings
how do your positions differ from jim
newman
um it's really the same thing i guess
it's all about the same thing
um i think one disadvantage you you
you definitely unpack these stages more
jim says no stages this is the absolute
stop seeing well he's
he's going at it from the the fifth the
natural state phase
so we also talked about how there is no
stages but you know some people like
stages of maps a little bit more than
others
yes yes um but you realize yeah there
are no maps or no stages
uh the whole diameter is empty but some
people just like to
teach from that position it's a good
reminder
but that if that's the only reminder you
have then
you could run into trouble too because
any extremes that you encounter on the
path could cause imbalance
yes yes just like we need everybody it's
all a dream
everything is one of course it's true
you're only one that exists there's no
cell there's no
there's no others that's one length of
perception
and like we said in the earlier video uh
true unity
true unity includes both oneness and
separateness
so there's nobody here kind of teaching
sort of exclude
the person the individual like we say
you want to be everybody nobody and
somebody
you want to be nowhere everywhere and
somewhere that's true
you wanna you we sort of operate on
three simon
simultaneously we operate simultaneously
on three levels
in a sense all the ultimate is just one
level like i don't exist
i exist as atlas and i exist as
every possibility yeah you exist as
infinity you exist as
uh nothingness yeah
beautiful and another aspect to this
that i find really important is that
frank would you say that the neo advice
just going direct to this is the
absolute
you're seeking home which is already
this
that type of thing would you say that
that like sort of direct pointer to that
fifth stage that we were listing in
the absolute normie episode would you
say that at least
to be so relentless with perpetually
pointing there at least makes it so that
people can know
like really quickly at least like okay
well this
is the end like this is the absolute
like
and then it sort of makes it maybe a
little bit more
could it be swift to sort of get
to that uh i i think so
um i think it's both you want to follow
that path
and simultaneously do the the passionate
path that for me is the most effective
and also there's also different uh
different stages of non-duality
you could feel like very you could feel
very down duel even
when you still have a center when this
the subject and the object
if there's still a duality it's not the
fullest non-duality but even
if there's a still a separation there
you could experience infinite
consciousness from
the separated state and still feel very
non-dual but there's a very subtle sense
of merging
that's still happening that's still not
true what i call unit locality so
my different stages of non-duality is
first you have non-duality oneness
awareness of awareness
second you have non-locality which is
emptiness and third you have uni
locality
now they're all just different aspects
non-duality
the deep form of a neurality becomes
unilocal
if you only speak of non-duality
without realizing that there are
different levels of non-duality at the
relative level because it takes a while
for you to dissolve
so some people who are still in the
beginning stage of non-duality think
that's it
but it's actually more dissolution
that's the difference between
feeling oneness still from the center
from the separate state
after dissolving a lot of the ego
conditions already versus
completely dropping over the center and
become unit local
yeah cool
and then how important
are retreats p.s i love you
i love that last part there that's so
cute
i love you too
i love you bro i love you bro
um yeah so in my experience retreats
one retreat you make more gains in one
tree than you do
sitting for an hour a day for the entire
year
because for some reason retreats just
gives you the extra boost because
it takes a while for you to you know go
really deep into the mind if you have a
lot of stimulus in everyday life you're
not going to go deep you know
you sit for an hour you wake up from
that uh from that meditation
for the meditation cushion you get up
and then
conditionings are piling up already as
long as you as soon as you get up
so to retreat you have no room for the
condition to rearrange because you're
constantly instead of silence so that's
why it's only on the like
fifth sixth day of the retreat that you
really experience something profound
because it takes that many days to get
subtler and subtle
levels of the mind until you
peel away all the surface level stuff
and you go deep within yourself
like you just can't get that um when you
sit for an hour a day or half an hour a
day
yeah and frank specifically mentioning
vipassana and i concur
that the
large part to why i
am where i'm at right now in
understanding
all of the these nuances around
spiritual awakening is because of
vipassana
and frank illustrated it perfectly
which is that you really do
need the long
period of
sitting repeatedly
to get to the roots as was taught by
buddha in this lineage of
extinguishing the most deepest roots
of the conditioning in the separate self
and the cravings and the aversions and
the attachments
and the
noble silence that is taken and the fact
that you have no
technology that you can access the fact
that you don't look at
anyone else in the eyes all of those
components
further amplify it's it is like going
super saiyan during that period of time
and
just don't necessarily get into
and frank has sort of done this in his
content he's talked about this process
but
he's sort of just perpetuating the cycle
of going and sitting
without also combining that with
do-nothing meditation and self-inquiry
and entheogens and
these other
for example reading the end of your
world or reading
you know i am that like these are good
books are also great
from the greatest sages are great
additions
to sitting on retreats
some people so first of all i mean i
can't speak for everyone but some people
they go to retreats and they go you know
they they're not very stabilized and
it encounters problems then they just
sit for an hour a day that could be
better for them or some people get into
a lot of crazy mystical states or
trees they can get attached to those
states
that could also be a problem there are
some teachers that advise against long
retreats for those reasons
but they're just you know advocating you
just paying attention to the present
moment right now
while doing everyday tasks or just sit
for half an hour here and there
so it all depends on the individual
multiple individuals
i'll say like if you if you don't know
what works for you just try them both
and see what happens
yeah and especially the try thing like
try and see how it
it is for you yeah cool
all right thoughts on public
intellectuals like jordan peterson sam
harris etc and why they often stay clear
of metaphysical discussion despite their
deep
insights into the mind and human
psychology
if you haven't yet listened to
jordan peterson and sam harris in their
discussions that they've had in
vancouver and
in london and
dublin i think that they've had great
discussions and brett weinstein and
douglas murray moderated them and
they basically do the synthesis of
spirituality
and science or you could say
they aim to find how to extract
out the best from both and merge them
together and then like get rid of the
stuff that doesn't work
basically and so they already do a good
job
at this stuff but they do it
from a perspective of like um
like like they can't
say something that
will put their uh
clout or fame or status
in jeopardy in a sense um
so they do it very carefully they do it
to avoid that
that's been like the number one thing
that i've noticed is that like right now
being 28
um like when i was 27 and i didn't
necessarily have
much experience with what i'm
talking about now with spiritual
awakening i wasn't doing i wasn't saying
this
i wasn't talking about this because i
had no experience with it
now i have experience with it so i talk
about it a bit and
i would say that maybe
jordan sam and
many of these other people that were in
like the intellectual dark web
may not necessarily have had
abiding awakening experience
and maybe they've had glimpses
but that then makes it so that they
don't have the direct experience and the
realization to be able to speak
from the place as well
you said it perfectly i i i don't have
to anything
okay all right cool that's what i always
said exactly what i've said
beautiful yeah frank and i are vibing on
deeper and deeper
wavelengths with the synchronicities
there i love that
and just another thing is that i i have
messaged eric weinstein and sam harris
and jordan peterson all within like the
last
couple of months um asking them to
for jordan to come back on the show and
for eric and sam to be featured on the
show
and i have not heard back from them and
i've specifically asked them
around these biggest metaphysical
subjects
so it was not hey jordan could we
promote your new book it was let's talk
about
what the nature of reality is and
um that can also be a little bit
again
difficult for somebody that's
you know in
yet at the same time it could be great
for society and great for civilization
for
one of them in this later state of their
career
to turn towards
the conversations around the nature of
reality
rather than the
and sam is very much doing this by the
way on like the waking up
podcast he just had jim newman on
like a couple months ago and he's been
having
uh
more and more some like zokchen masters
this type of stuff on the on the program
so it is
great but at also at some point
what about like not
focusing on the
political polarization and just sort of
taking a firm stance in
empty infinity what about taking a firm
stance in that what about taking a
stance of saying i'm not
sam harris but i'm actually life itself
i'm nothing everything and sam harris
what about
that stance what about and sharing that
with the world
so it's just it could be a little bit
more
exciting for society and civilization to
have some of these bigger figures
sort of take a a deeper step into those
direct realizations
that they've had cool okay
all right and then let's have frank do
this one
are babies and animals enlightened
well i mean natural state is kind of
like you see no distinction between you
and animals
no babies or anybody else um i i think
in
i guess enlightenment is kind of like
the the combination of a
of a state of an animal or babies yet on
top of that
version of that so now you have to
distinguish between the
post and trans-human fallacy
ken wilber talks about this he says our
baby's enlightened he says no because
they haven't ruined the ego yet
you have to grow the ego and then just
identify from the ego that's
that's why we go back to holland the
spiritual path is about being identified
with certain states and then
disidentifying from you have to
access it before you can disappear into
it before you can collapse into it
so i would say like um enlightened state
is kind of like
uh you have a brain of a baby but also
of an old person and a young person too
many animals
in god and everything
so it's like having that it's having the
meta awareness
of this natural state because if you're
only in the natural state and you don't
have the metacognition of it
then see you have the ego stay in this
side
and you have the the baby state or the
animals stay inside they're almost like
two opposite side of the extreme right
and i guess in linemen it's almost like
the synthesis of
the middle way of both the self
the ego and the completeness of
babies and animals
so the pre and trans human fallacy is
like
don't mistaken a child who can draw like
picasso to be picasso
to be able to draw like picasso picasso
first has to
learn how to draw like a classical
painter he has to paint like raphael
before he can abstract from the rougher
out
so saying baby sideline is like saying
elephants campaign like
oh sorry picasso or saying babies their
finger paintings is like picasso
that's the difference between pre and
post knowledge
even though on the surface they might
look the same just like how
you know people like wild
uh our ancestors the hudson gatherers
are there in the natural state yes and
no
they're in a pre-knowledge phase
it's going through civilization and then
going back to the natural state
i merge the post and pre-knowledge
that's what i have to say about that
cool yeah and we talked about that a bit
on the absolute normie episode as well
where
the birthing especially an indigeneity
of children without
the egoic separate self-conditioning
forming is almost acting like a gateway
into that
natural state and that is a main
component of
as we talk about putting together these
pedagogies for
young kids especially to undergo the
process
of recognizing their true nature from
age 5 10 15 is awesome
and then we could potentially see that
type of civilization a hundred years
from now where it is very simultaneously
startrekian and also very
monastery and also very
ecologically harmonious and
just abundant prosperous
everyone being actualized and realized
so exciting
cool yeah frank and i are working on
that this question has like
a couple of different wobbles because
like sometimes when you abide in that
dark cloud the absolute
there's not even a a meta cognition of
like awakening or anything like that
so like that state it's almost like just
think of the state of the universe
before there was any humans
or before you were born before the big
bang
and after big crunch even like just
contemplate what that state is like
no construction uh
projection of even spirituality itself
what is it like perfect
yeah you know is that the same state as
the baby is that the same state as like
deers trees even or bugs
perfect perfect frank perfect and the
last question
is how does driving feel like in the
natty state
um i think again the best way to
describe this
is it's just the universe driving itself
when you walk it's just
when you move your feet is the the whole
universe is driving the feet and vice
versa
and it is just the universe eating um
well
i mean if you want to analyze it it
could feel like you're driving headless
it could feel like you could feel like
you're not going anywhere because you
know infinity doesn't really go anywhere
like you're this huge
field of awareness and you're just
driving within this
this dharma body this is what i call the
dharma body
it's when you have no separation at all
between you and the universe
the entire universe feels like your body
and you're driving
inside this body as this body so you're
not really going anywhere
but at the same time everything's moving
simultaneously at the speed of light
through dependent originations
so you get two levels the absolute goo
of homogeneity
and the relative group of the links of
dependent origination
of the heterogeneity happening
simultaneously
i mean it's trippy man i remember the
the the first time i went downstairs
after the big bang i was like
i couldn't even walk straight i was like
this this thing's
[ __ ] huge man like like it's like i
don't have a head or a body
it's like i don't have a mind or a body
it's just the world it's just the war as
itself doing its thing
so this question is funny because
driving during that state is the same as
walking or eating during that state
this is driving it's a little bit more
trippy because you're
you're moving you're moving in this
it's hard to explain i think that's why
people like to go on walks like a lot of
damn masters
they like to contemplate when they walk
if there's movement
um in a sense you can kind of observe
and investigate
um the state you can pronounce the state
even more fully sometimes when you're
engaging in sort of this embodied task
of
washing the dishes and you know um
carrying the water and chopping wood
right
that's what i was trying to indicate to
you in the absolute normie episode
when i was saying as you're walking into
the fridge you take a stop yes
yeah yeah type thing yeah exactly
yeah and also when we were talking about
the
cleaning out the very dirty garbage can
having that same empty fullness
as watching the hummingbirds
okay so like driving is not different
from any other state
at some point everything you do just
becomes one seamless whole like there's
no difference between
waking state there's no difference
between that and the sleeping state
dreamless sleep even or the dream state
it's just one seamless haul because when
you're constantly in like samadhi
it's going back and forth between those
different relative dream levels it's
really just the same thing
okay beautiful holy beautiful first
q a together there were a lot
of questions in the comments that i
would love
for everyone that wrote a question in
the live chat
if you could post your question in the
comments of this ama
and what we'll do is we'll grab the
questions from
the comments of the ama and we'll put
those into the next
ama document and rank order those and
answer them on the next one
and
we feel like you could potentially
expect that maybe in like six or so
weeks like a month and a half or so
and thank you everyone for
tuning in and
frank for being so just
concise and on the dot thank you
thank you atlas thank you for having
yeah that was really fun super
every every every episode with you oh we
still live for it
yeah yeah every episode with you has
been super fun we'll always cover deep
uh
yeah and it's definitely hugely a part
of like frank's continued exploration of
spiritual awakening
that has gotten me deepening the
realizations on my into
it's been super important for so many
others and
again the links in the bio are to
frank's instagram
he's got great content on there
especially on his stories he unpacks the
deepening of the realizations there
go follow him and check those out and
also subscribe to his youtube channel he
has great content that he's been posting
there as well
especially his last two videos go and
check that out
if this video ama brought you value give
it a like it helps the algorithm
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet
and share the video with other people
that you feel like this would profoundly
influence
and that is all again if you have
questions that you would like to line up
for the second
ama do write them in the comments below
and then we will grab them and put them
into
the next ama pool
so infinite love thank you everyone
thanks frank
all right bye everyone